well I think that's a questionably the
case I listened or not to what you and
other commentators say I listen to what
the pollsters are saying I even take
some cognizance of the views of the
bookmakers and everybody seems to be
indicating that it's going to be a hung
parliament so I'm not going to deny all
of those facts and I think that we have
to recognize that it might be a
parliament that is so diverse that even
two political parties may not be able to
make up the numbers necessary to govern
yes and if the predictions are right
there will be a significant block of
unionist certainly Democratic unionists
here at Westminster what is your
condition for getting involved in
supporting one side or the other in
terms of formula government well we've
had a very good relationship with both
the Labour Party under Conservative
Party in the past and we've been able to
work with the Liberal Democrats and
particularly with Danny Alexander and
finance so because we are a devolved
institution we've had a good
relationship and knew all of the
personalities and could work with them
so it really is at the end of the day an
issue of our north and ireland plan
where we have said I'd 45 key issues
that we would want to discuss which is
our vision for Northern Ireland the
issues that I think would make Northern
Ireland into an economic powerhouse that
deal with the issues of our public
services in Northern Ireland that look
to the strengthening of the United
Kingdom and matters of course that in
creating opportunity and furnace for
everyone so we look at all of those
issues and we've quite honestly we will
see who is offering the most of our
vision for Northern Ireland on the
United Kingdom in terms of where we're
prepared to to give our support one of
the things you also want is a
constitutional convention would that be
a precondition for deciding who you give
your votes to well that's a proposal and
I I don't regard it as being uniquely
mine because Curren Curren Jones of the
Labour Party the first minister of
wheels has also been putting
proposition I the mind goes slightly
further because I think carmen was
looking essentially at the structures of
the United Kingdom and arrangements
within the United Kingdom I think we
really do need to start looking at
policy matters and how they affect the
regions and I don't think that it is
helpful to to give messages out to the
the people of Scotland that if they vote
in a certain way they're not going to be
listened to I think they must be
Parliament and the minds of any of the
the party leader so it's not just an
issue that has red line in terms of
getting into gamma this is an issue that
has to be taken on board by the Prime
Minister I'm by the leader of opposition
whoever either of them may be and the
recognition of course is that there will
be perhaps 50 to 60 nationalist members
of parliament in the next parliament
from Scotland from wheels and from
Northern Ireland and there is on death
row gravity to try and break up the
United Kingdom our job as union
assistant sure that we went in and
strengthen the United Kingdom and in
that context I want the party leader who
Union parties after the election when
all of slanging of the election is out
of the way to work together whether it's
a compact whether it's a a council for
the Union or whether it's some kind of
commission to work together in order to
sell the Union to those who are
questioning the future of their
particular part of the United Kingdom as
part of that union certainly it looks as
if it were to be Mr Miliband and labor
that were to form a minority government
they would need at the very least the
support of the votes of the SNP could
you possibly be in a close relationship
with a Labour minority government in
those circumstances well first of all
we've we've made it very clear we want
nothing for ourselves we don't want to
be part of a coalition we don't want any
poster positions we simply want to get
the best possible deal for Northern
Ireland and one that is satisfactory to
the United Kingdom as a whole if members
of the Scottish National Party are
giving support to a labor minority
administration on issues which are for
the
our people Kingdom I don't think we
should rubbish that proposition if I
ever they're looking in exchange for
that to get any concession that weakens
our gets a separation by stealth they're
clearly we would oppose out and we
wouldn't want to be part of any such
arrangement you say you're a little bit
concerned by the way the Conservatives
have approached this as far as their ass
your attitude towards the Scottish
voters are concerned do you think that
on the labor side they are being firm
enough about their relationship with the
nationalists well actually I'm not sure
that the two parties are taking a
different attitude in terms of how they
would view the SNP the Labour Party is
saying that they won't deal with them
they Conservative Party is saying that
you shouldn't deal with them as in many
ways they they are getting the boots and
amongst the boots that the SNP will get
will be votes of those who voted to
remain within the United Kingdom in the
recent referendum so don't be telling
those people that if you vote in a
particular way on economic issues or
social issues we don't want to hear from
you because you vote for the SNP your
persona non grata I think we have to
look at the issues if there is any move
towards separation then I believe that
all of the pro-union party should be
rallying together to stop that from
happening but I think we should remember
that the Democratic voice of those
people of Scotland should not be ignored
on social and economic issues or else we
start to estrange people in Scotland
from the United Kingdom you've got a
very different voting system for the
Stormont assembly do you think that in
the Westminster election the time for
first-past-the-post has passed good
gracious no you're absolutely certain if
you bring in some PR system such as
first pass there are such as the
multiple member constituencies you will
undoubtedly end up in every election
with some form of coalition and
coalition building being part of it I
believe in having a united kingdom that
has a firm and strong stable government
and you are more likely to get that from
first-past-the-post I know there are
furnaces that are built into that system
but already we can see a shred
of the boots of men parties and the UK I
think in time that will continue to be a
direction of trouble for the voters of
the United Kingdom but if you have PR
you can be absolutely certain that
you'll end up with mayhem and what's
your guests you think we lend out having
to general elections this year well it
certainly is a possibility and I don't
think that anybody that has gone through
the fixed Parliament process which
effectively has meant that we have had
five months of an election Campion will
look forward to having another one in
this year but I think there are
obviously possibilities and the
electorate must have the final say and
these matters but if the electorate give
a result which shows that they want a
multiplicity and political parties to
have a say in the future government of
the United Kingdom you know are we right
to second guess them and say no we're
going to go back to the pools to get a
different result because we didn't like
what they they offered us in the first
place I think there must be a real
effort made to see if we can actually
construct some kind of consensus
government on the basis of the result
that comes from the main 7th election